hi willkommen zu Block 18 eigentlich
hätte ich heute Nina chuber herself
interviewt gebt euch das mal aber vlogm
kickt richtig rein und wir sind
mittlerweile so kaputt dass wir das
absagen mussten also es wäre so ein R
roter Teppich Interview Situation
gewesen und wir haben gesagt nee das ist
ein bisschen too much
heute aber worauf wir richtig Lust haben
nachdem wir heute schon den ganzen Tag
gearbeitet haben und das Video für heute
fertig gemacht haben und Pipo auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt gehen und zwar
mit dieser essbahn die bringt uns jetzt
dahin auf den historischen
weihnachtsbahkass
vergessen schon Hunger nachdem dein
Mittagessen eher nicht so lecker war
dadurch dass wir keine Zeit hatten zu
kochen mussten wir uns Essen bestellen
geht ja in Berlin super einfach ist ja
auch eigentlich kein Problem mein Essen
war furchtbar also ich habe noch nie so
ins Klo gegriffen und sowas also ich bin
ein Allesfresser man kann mir wirklich
alles hinstellen und bevor ich es
wegschmeiße esse ich es das konnte ich
nicht essen also die Hälfte habe ich
gegessen die andere Hälfte konnte ich
nicht essen anyways deswegen habe ich
extrem Hunger und freue mich es sieht
draußen aus als ob es schon Feierabend
wä 23 Uhr Kreuz Übergang
zu
46 85 und zum Regionalverkehr kommt auch
so vor wir machen jetzt seit 17 Tagen
blogm du filmst mich hier gerade mit
einer fetten Kamera in der SBahn es
juckt uns einfach gar nicht mehr ne Auer
gestern reingekickt Herren gesehen hab
gestern war unangenehm ne ja bisschen
schön aber es hat sich auch angefühlt
als ob man bei den zu Hause gewesen wä
schon irgendwie schon wie war noch so
süß und knuffig da wollte ich irgendwie
nicht so die ganze zeitk von Youtube na
ja gut bis gleich sieht aus als ob wir
in so ein technoc landen würden kommt
lst uns zum Weihnachtsmarkt Technoclub
ich sehe auch ein bisschen so aus Outfit
wir sind gerade auf dem RAW Gelände das
ist direkt beim bei der Warschauer
Straße also neben dem amazonauer einfach
auf die andere Seite gucken hier ist
noch alles rough ist Berlin urbanes
Berlin cool Gangster Clubs
Biergärten ja und ganz viele Touristen
und Flohmarkt hier haben wir unseren
Flohmarkt gemacht genau auf RW Gelände
ist eigentlich so ein Standard program
bei Touristen muss man sagen ne ich
glaube schon ja obwohl eigentlich noch
fast schon mehr ist der beim Mauerpark
oh ja der ist so der übelste
touristische okay s komplett in der
Dunkelheit hier kostet der sogar
Eintritt 3 € Eintritt ist mehr als am
jendarmmkt also der muss gut
sein auf den Straßen Berlins sind wir
unterwegs hey ich glaube da vorne ist
doch sogar Flohmarkt oder ach heute ist
Sonntag das ist der Flohmarkt das ist
aber wo ist denn dann der historische
Weihnachtsmarkt hoffe mal wir sind
richtig oder ja die packen gerade ein
historischer Weihnachtsmark da ist ein
Schild das sieht aus als ob die Klasse
4b aus Steglitz es selbst gebastelt
hätte hallo Ich ist ihre touristenfüin
Vanessa wir gehen mal
rein schön guten Tag ich bin hier auf
dem historischen Weihnachtsmarkt in
friedrichshin
hier drüben sehen wir einen ATM eine
kassenmaschine wo man sein Bargeld
rauskriegen kann ein
originalhistorisches relegt aus ich
würde mal schätzen ungefähr 50 vor
Christi und ich war noch nie hier ich
hoffe mir aber sehr viel denn der
Eintritt kostet 3 € zum gendarmmarkt
Weihnachtsmarkt muss man immer 1 €
bezahlen und der jendarmmk weihnach
Markt ist schon sehr krass aber ich habe
schon gesehen hier gibt es axtwer erfen
hier kann man verschiedene Spiele
spielen für Kinder ist hier wirklich
sehr viel dabei was uns an dieser Stelle
nicht interessiert was uns aber
interessiert ist der Glühwein und da
gehen wir auch gleich mal hin man kann
schon sagen das ist so ein bisschen
Ritterfest mis Weihnachtsmarkt hier hast
du auch die trolleburg das ist
wahrscheinlich ein Kind Spiel für Kinder
was mir hier echt gut gefällt ist ist
wirklich der absolute Kontrast zu diesen
Jahrmärkten Weihnachtsmärkten also an
der Landsberger Allee haben wir ein
Weihnachtsmarkt der gleicht eher einem
Jahrmarkt und ist sehr la viel Plasti
viel gebr über laute Musik und es
irgendwie schön hier die Spiele zu sehen
die so ein bisschen kindgerechter wirken
ein bisschen ruhiger ein bisschen so aus
Holz pädagogisch wertvoll an dieser
[Musik]
Stelle ich muss mal ganz kurz mit euch
über diesen Boden reden ich wei ist
super kleines Detail aber das ist das
Zeug was wir auch im Garten meiner
Mutter verteilt haben und ich stehe da
mega drauf darauf rumzulaufen man f sich
es fühlt sich so weich an weißt du du
hast nicht so irgendwie sind liegen hier
keine Kippen es ist hier so richtig
ordentlich und weich und man läuft hier
so ein bisschen wie auf Federn ich bin
richtig begeistert
gerade schön ich habe mich gerade
richtig am Glühweinstand blamiert er hat
gesagt 14 € und ich war so schockiert
für zwei Glühweine und dann meinte ich
ja 3 € pfandprecher so ja und ein
Glühwein kostet hier 4€
superiril ganz viele weihnachtsmk haben
schon für 5 € na ja 4 + 4 8 + 3 + 3 ist
14 als ich diese Rechnung in meinem Kopf
fertig gemacht habe hat er mich
angeschaut und ich bin beschämt einfach
nur weggegangen und jetzt probieren wir
diesen tollen Glühwein für 4
€ boah lecker schmeckt irgendwie voll
kirschig so fruchtig ich glaube aber da
stand do sogar fruchtgühwein oder ja
aber ich habe
normalen aber ich find ihn sehr lecker
und ist sehr schön heiß okay Prost Prost
glüber Nummer 1 willkommen bei Wer wird
Millionär hier ist die 1 Million Euro
Frage wie lange bleiben Kinder auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt a 18 Uhr B 20 Uhr oder C
22 Uhr schreibt jetzt in die Kommentare
oh mein Gott wie geil wäre das wenn
unser Hochzeit wenn wir auch so ein
bisschen so
ritterlich ritterlich ja wenn wir auch
so Mullen überall hätten und alle würden
so in traditionellen Anzügen
ich schon bisschen sehr heftig irgendwie
wir kommen so alle mit Ritterrüstung
aber so eine Hochzeit wo so ein bisschen
Jahrmarktstimmung ist dass du so ein
bisschen was werfen kannst und so und
dann und das Geld was man dort verdient
wir machen wir erkoren so fünf Leute die
sich ein Stand überlegen müssen so
random und mit diesen Ständen draußen
und mit diesen Ständen finanzieren wir
die Hochzeit ne nehmen wir ein bisschen
Geld ein und die Leute können dann halt
so kleine Sachen gewinnen und so ich
habe dann ja meine Pr Pakete pack ich
pack ich leer random dann haben so fünf
Leute Stände und dann können die Gäste
halt so Wort jmk Flohmarkt möchte nicht
mit meiner Hochzeit verbinden das ist so
von na ja du machst dann so Dosenwerfen
z.B und
dann ich will meine Hochzeit Dosen
werfen haben ist do voll
cool weiß ich nicht ich nicht so
wirklich ich sitz mal weiter auf der
Idee
[Musik]
rum
okay Tast Test ich habe rich die Bock
wir gehen
rein
boah die
geil Biss nach Kümmel aber rtig
geil genau das was man will wenn man
Glühwein getrunken hat merk so ein
bisschen wie so Käsestange irgendwie ne
ja aber wie ein Fett es ist ein
fettfreierer Käse es ist nicht so ein
fertiger
Käse ja aber 6 € für F cheeseballs schon
heftig ne ist schon krass aber denk mal
an die Schweiz hätest du jetzt 30 dafür
gezahlt der Schweiz hätten wir unser
Haus dafür abgeben
[Musik]
müssen
ein muss ich mindestens
reinkriegen richtig mit Schmack
ist mit
Wut gibt ein
Tipp
[Musik]
jetzt
ich glaube die habt ihr nicht gut
geschärft
[Musik]
oh
ja ganze K nach vorne das war der Tip
der gefehlt
hat icheall
geworfenall holzock aberch soem harten
wur bra Essen oderemtenur bra
das ist ein
Esel guck mal da s ein Esel oh ist das
goldig ich weiß aber nicht ob das gut D
soll auch nicht was anni wir Fragen kurz
Anni und jetzt schneide ich ihre Meinung
rein zu Pferden und Eseln auf dem
historischenem Weihnachtsmarkt meine
Meinung zu ponyarussells ist eine ganz
klare und zwar das geht gar nicht mehr
ich glaube das ist absolut nicht
zeitgemäß Tierquälerei da hat keiner was
von außer die Betreiber die 5 € für eine
Runde Ponyreiten benutzen und ich kann
verstehen dass es für Kinder gerade aus
Berlin eine ganz ganz coole Attraktion
ist aber den Fahrt do auch nach
Brandenburg auf Erlebnisbauernhof
streichelt die Tiere füttert die Tiere
lernt sie alle so ein bisschen kennen
anstatt 5 Minuten an diesem Gatter zu
stehen und einfach ein Esel zu
streicheln der eigentlich gar nicht da
sein will als nächstes sehen wir den
klassischen
[Musik]
kartoffelspieß
danke krankes Riesenteil wir haben einen
perfekten bekommen sie hatte nicht so
ein perfekten in der Hand und einen
perfekten und wir haben den perfekten
aber geil mit diesem
flammenlicht Taste
Test Hammer ist
geil super geil
einf das die beste
Erfindung das ist wirklich die beste
Erfindung die es jemals gab es ist eine
Kartoffel und die ist so langezogen dass
man das Gefühl hat was richtig Großes zu
essen weil ich erwachsen bin kriege ich
mein eigenes das Kind neben mir he auch
ihr eigenes haben bekommt sie nicht weil
sie ein Kind ist jetzt waren wir bei der
hexenschenke und für Timo gibt's wieder
rot und für mich gibt's weißen Glühwein
kostet 1 € mehr
warum
ich habe eine ganze Zeit lang weißen
Glühwein getrunken weil ich dachte dass
ich von Rotwein super doll Kopfschmerzen
Kriege turns out wenn ich nicht viel
lang halt gemachte Lebensmittel esse
dann kann ich auch ab und zu mal Rotwein
trinken und Glühwein in rot ohne dass
ich kin Kopfschmerzen kriegt aber der
weiße der gibt ein ist nicht so süß muss
ich sagen der ist so ein
bisschen chilliger also unsere Meinung
über den Weihnachtsmarkt der wird nicht
schlechter ne nö jetzt noch de
grandiosen Wurf da beim Axtwerfen würde
ich mal sagen ze von ze also das war der
letzte und dann hat Timo noch in
Slowmotion aufgenommen wir wollten
einfach den letzten noch mal in
Slowmotion aufnehmen damit wir noch eine
coole Aufnahme davon haben und dann
war's der und jetzt git's gleich noch
mal Langosch aber vorher eine kleine
Trinkpause weil wir sind so
[Musik]
durstig
mit muschelbrötchen haben sie nicht
gelogen es ist ein muschelbrötchen es
ist ein Brötchen das aussieht wie eine
Muschel das ist das erste Mal in meinem
Leben dass ich flamlachs probiere es ist
nicht sehr viel Lachs auf dem rötchen ne
neben mir stand eine sie kommt extra aus
Großbären zu diesem Weihnachtsmarkt um
den flammlachs zu essen also dann l
schmecken redet immer über flammenl und
dem flamml
deswegen scht nach LA und Brötchen die
Zwiebeln sind lecker und geflammter
Lachs oder geflamm und die Verkäufer
waren cool war echt cool ne ja die
Verkäufer war schmeckst auch die Flamme
die Flamme raus so oder ich schmeck die
Flamme raus ja aber sehr viel für meinen
Geschmack zu viel karamisierte Zwiebeln
drauf ich schmecke mehr Zwiebeln als
Lachs gerade und ich glaube das ist
nicht der Sinn der Sache probier hier
noch mal eine Ecke mit sehr viel
lach
se gut ich würde nicht aus Großbären
dafür kommen aber hier sieht das Stück
aber ganz schön groß aus der Lachs oder
täuscht es nur n das ist schon vi Dings
aber das ist glaub ich nicht mein taste
ich lieb Lachs aber mir ist zu viel los
ich mag den puren Lachs Geschmack da mir
zu viel los haben jetzt noch gar nicht
gefeaturt es gibt auch mittelalterliche
oder historische Kleidung sage ich jetzt
mal na ja zumindest noch abseits von
Essensständen gibt's auch noch hier
irgendwie stuff Leute ne ich fang es
zwar überhaupt ganz schlecht gerade ein
aber sie existieren gerade schon gesagt
auf camera vanessa war zu lange in der
Schweiz und hat zu viel fein dining da
gegessen
hier das kickt sie nicht mehr
muschelbrötchen was das ist hier kickt
nicht wo ist das Blatt goldold ich hole
mir jetzt noch ein lamgosch
[Musik]
tschüss auf
jawoll danke der klassic egal auf auf
dem historischen oder nicht historischen
Langosch ist auf einem Weihnachtsmarkt
vertreten vertreten und absolut ein Muss
Weihnachtsmarkt ist nicht
Weihnachtsmarkt ohne langorch und der
sieht hier wirklich sehr gut aus aber
der Käse wird halt nicht schmelzen ne
aber nie so bei
lang glaube ich nicht
ne das ist ein hammerlangos das ist ein
hammerlang ich habe das Gefühl die
letzten die wir gegessen haben die war
nicht so gut der ist hammer du willst
lieben oh mein Gott geil der dreht am
Rad der bur der dreht am
Rad wow der schleudert wenn er noch
schneller dreht schleudert er das Kind
raus aber er dreht in die falsche
Richtung wofür ist das
denn goldig oder ja wirklich uns ist
schlecht wir suchen jetzt den
Heimweg hier gibt's noch ganz viel Kram
den wir kaufen
könnten
ich will hier bleiben will das Kind
gehört wie krank gehult hat das Kind
wollte wirklich nicht nach Hause gehen
aber man denkt dann auch immer so was
haben die Eltern gemacht dass das Kind
so Kind wollte unter gar kein Umständen
gehen das war so krankes Protest heulen
hat aber so richtig gezogen die Mutter
musste sie so richtig mit ihren Bein so
mitschieben so du gehst jetzt aber raus
ich war als Kind halt so ein übelst
friedvolle wie ich war mal ein bisschen
wie auf so Wolke 7 so ja dann machen wir
das außer eine Situation da wollte ich
einen Hund und da hatten wir schon einen
Hund angeschaut den wir vielleicht
potenziell kaufen können aber der hatte
irgendwie so kaputte Zähne und war schon
zu alt und deswegen hatten meine Eltern
gesagt sie nehmen ihn doch nicht mit und
da habe ich den halben Vormittag
geschrien in meinem ich weiß noch das
war das einzige Mal wo ich so richtig
geweint habe und extra laut geweint habe
dass meine Eltern das auch bloß hören
ich habe so das ganze Haus
so hab ich auch so getan als ob ich so
Schnappatmung Krieg so das war immer die
heftigsten Heuler wenn man so wenn so
richtig Schnappatmung eingesetzt hat das
war wirklich
so so wir verlassen jetzt die ganze
Geschichte hier wir könnten auch noch
feiern gehen ins ciopaya es hat auf hab
gerade gesehen tetim und ich hatten
schon wilde Nächte hier auf dem EW
Gelände aber heute ist keine wilde Nacht
er möchte nämlich the finals spielen und
deswegen hauen wir jetzt mal ab ich
möchte auch meinen Dicken kleinen Arsch
auf meine Couch machen mir eine Decke
holen irgend scheiß auf Koreanisch
anmachen und dabei einschlummern ich bin
bisschen traurig ich sag's euch ganz
ehrlich heute ist der 17 heute ist
montes Event und ich habe gesehen dass
montes skievent in der bisbinger
Skihalle ist im snowdome da wo wir
Skifahren gelernt haben und ich wäre so
gerne auf diesem Event gewesen ich
eigentlich nicht eigentlich hat es mich
nicht so interessiert ich habe davon
immer gehört aber jetzt wo ich weiß dass
es einfach in der Skihalle bisbing ist
bin ich richtig neidisch Mann ich Werre
da die ganze Zeit runtergedüst und alle
hätten gesagt h ist das mewne
malwne fährt aber ganz schön gut Ski die
fährt doch erst zwei Wochen okay tschüss